[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
wie ihr ganz leckere hähnchenschenkel
machen könnt und zwar mit meiner
lieblings marinade und wie schmeckt
einfach unfassbar lecker ich kenne
keinen der so nicht um auch tat und wir
brauchen gar nicht so viele zutaten und
zwar sind das 100 milliliter gemüsebrühe
drei esslöffel tomatenketchup 1
esslöffel braunen zucker einen teelöffel
könig 2 esslöffel sojasauce und ein
esslöffel essig grenze geht jetzt auch
super schnell ihr müsst einfach nur alle
zutaten miteinander vermischen
ich nehme zuallererst ketchup und
gemüsebrühe und verhöre das gut
miteinander
[Musik]
dann kommen auch schon die restlichen
zutaten hinzu alles wird noch mal gut
vermischt und dann ist die marinade auch
schon fertig die marinade reicht in
meinem fall 15 chens schenke ihr könnt
aber auch zb 20 uhr in italien mit einem
pinsel funktioniert das ganze jetzt am
allerbesten jetzt müsst ihr nur noch die
hähnchenschenkel mit der marinade
bestreichen und in eine auflaufform
geben
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit könnt ihr den ofen
schon mal auf 200 grad ober und
unterhitze vorhalten bitte wundert euch
nicht ihr werdet noch ein teil der
marinade üblich haben das brauchen wir
auch später noch wenn die
hähnchenschenkel die kombiniert zu aller
erst für 15 minuten in den ofen dann
nehmen wir sie raus und bestreichen sie
noch mal mit der marinade
[Musik]
nach weiteren 15 minuten wird sie dann
mit der restlichen marinade bestrichen
und kommt zu weiteren fünf minuten in
den ofen
und wenn ihr dazu noch als serviert dann
habt ihr ein super leckeres menü was ich
auch noch gerne mache ist dass ich den
rest der soße dem ihr dann in der
auflaufform habt über den reifen über
die hähnchenschenkel giese und dann
lasst ihr euch das ganze schmecken
falls euch das video gefallen hat dann
freue ich mich über einen kommentar und
oder abo und denkt dran im monat ramadan
werde ich jeden zweiten tag ein neues
video hochladen
bis zum nächsten mal auf wiki sketchen
[Musik]